So what we're going to look at now is
the relationship between the inter process communication time and
both the individual and the mutual clock drift that
I described to you. Let Mu be the lower
bound on the inter process communication time. So
let's now derive the conditions under which we can
assert that if we have an event A on P I. And in real time, it's supposed to
precede an event B on Pj. What are the conditions that should hold in terms of
mu, k, the individual clock drift time, and
epsilon that is the mutual clock drift time?
This first condition is pretty straightforward, It is
coming from the fact that Ideally, the clocks
are perfectly synchronized. You know that at time, real time t, ci of t and cj
of t should be exactly the same, right? You expect that
if it is, if the clocks are perfectly synchronized and it is
keeping with real time, ci of t is equal to cj
of t, equal to t, where t is the real time. But
they could be in the original clock drift and user clock
drift, which makes them different from each other. And all that you're
seeing through this first one is that this is the act of
sending a message and this is the act of receiving the message.
The time stamp that I'm going to give to this,
the real time that I'm going to give to this
by reading my clock it better be higher than the
time at which the message is actually sent. And in
order to guarantee that we have to look at what
would be the time that it takes for this message
to go from here to here. That's coming from this
mu this lower bound on IPC. So, if the message
is sent at Ci of t with respect to Pi. Then, the time on PI when this message
is received over here, is going to be CI T plus mu. This is a local reading
of the clock, when the message would have
arrived at PJ. So this is the time elapsed
between sending the message, and when my peers should
have received the message. So, what we are saying
is in order for making sure that pj will have a time stamp that is at least
greater than Ci, you want to make sure that the, the time reading that I have
on my local clock, t plus mu, should
be greater than the time reading at the time
that I sent the message. So the time that I sent the message from Pi my pierce
time was CG of t and and all that we are saying is in order to make sure that
there is no anomaly the first condition has to hold that says that. The
disparity between the two clocks is within this
interprocess communication plane. That's all this is saying, that
the disparity of the mutual drift is within
this interprocess communication plane. And the second equation is
basically a difference equation formulation of the formula that
I gave you, which I called PC1. And this
is basically saying that if K is zero when I read the clock at time key plus new
and see the difference between the clock reading now
and the clock reading when I read it at
time T it should exactly be mu. But because
of the fact that I may have individual clock drift,
it may not be exactly mu, but it
may be something different from mu. Either more or
less, but very small difference. And so all
that we are saying is that the amount of
individual clock drift should be negligible compared to
the interprocess communication time. So the first thing is
saying the interprocess communication time is much bigger than any
clock drift that exists between two different clocks.
And the second equation is saying that the individual clock drift is very small
compared to mu. And if we put all these things together, you can derive the
expression for inter-process communication time. What it
should be relative to mutual drift and individual
clock drift. If this inequality is satisfied,
you can avoid anomalies in your distributive system.
So, informally, would you expect this k
is very very small. Which means the denominator
is very close to one. So, all that we're saying here is that the mutual
clock drift, which is represented by epsilon,
is very small compared to the interprocess communication
time. Which is what is captured by this apparent condition that I laid out here.